bonjour pour commencer je citerai
patrick bosso qui disait pas de stress
ya point s aujourd'hui je reçois l'homme
le plus cool du monde bonjour soyez le
bienvenu ici
kevin tu sais tu peux me tutoyez ballet
ah bon merci bah du coup est ce que tu
vas bien kiev - là on a la coupe
vraiment pas moins cool est ce que tu
vas bien ma poule
voilà la détente et le papa hockey
bienvenu ici poteau c'est cool mais
quand sa secte à changer de fringues
amigo ce qui se trouve que la salopette
vient juste de devenir à la mode
kewell poteau hashtag bien vu hashtag
visionnaire d'al hamra dachnak
auxquelles m la salopette
dommage que ça soit plus autant à la
mode calais paul biya 5 secondes
mister too late comment je suis trop deg
mais du coup comment on fait pour être
là qu'on faut faire quoi d'autre déjà
s'arrêter de poser des questions parce
que je sais que tu enlève quelque chose
mettez bien sur la table pris de malaise
ok tu as raison parce que comme j'ai des
double ne joue que depuis je les garde
mes shoes ne sont pas trop cool sans
déconner recul mon pote c'est que si tu
continues comme ça tu es risque de
devenir encore plus cool que moi c'est
vrai et ça c'est plutôt mégalo vivement
vendredi j'ai envie de te faire un
follow friday c'est quoi un flot frais
des locaux n'est pas twitter le blogueur
même givet dessus mais pas hyper souvent
j'aime bien t'es cool parce que tu
prends une complète distances avec les
réseaux sociaux et ça ça me met dans un
état d'extase mais du coup aussi c'est
quoi qui par cool pour toi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse pas les gens qu'ils avec
leur propre statut ce qui met des
chaussures sans chaussettes les filtres
sur instagram touléco cas sauf le zéro
les requins blancs le diesel et antec
morceaux les pèse-personnes la gastro
les boutons de manchettes et surtout les
phrases de plus de 60 mo qui pourra
compter à 12h59 world
trop cool que vous ne sait pas tout mais
là dans 20 minutes j'ai mon cours de
zumba
ça c'est le plus haut vers coup du coup
luc ouellet zumba n'a jamais été cool et
s'est testé je crois que tu m'a un peu
déçu c'est dommage j'aurais voulu que tu
sois aussi cool que marco man she trop
deg je me suis trouvée avoir acheté trop
la honte hashtag finul acheter
tous les meubles il est temps pour moi
de faire le truc le plus cool du monde
des charades nom du break dance
si toi tu as laissé passer sa chance
bon ben c'est tout pour aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de vous donner rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine je recevrai le
champion du monde 2012 2013 2014 de
cache-cache faudra d'abord retrouver